what do you do if you're the the target
of this mob what do you do if your
billboard Chris what do you do if you
are being shattered down while filming
in Texas what if you what do you do if
you're Alex Stein being beaten up by the
mob and you see the cops just standing
around doing nothing it's probably a
good sign that you're on the right side
all of this is foretold in the Bible all
of this is foretold in non-biblical
sources as well if you're being attacked
by the mob you're probably saying
something right if you're getting a lot
of Praise from the world then you're
probably doing something wrong if you're
getting a lot of Praise from the world
very likely uh you're on the wrong side
because this world is governed by the
devil is governed by principalities and
powers and spiritual awakenness in high
places and people know it and that's why
more and more people believe in hell
even if they don't believe in heaven and
they don't believe in God